the general theory of relativity is
Einsteins pinnacle achievement it is one
of the deepest scientific discoveries
when the deepest scientific insights of
all time and it all has to do with the
force of gravity so as you probably
remember from high school way back in
the 1600s Isaac Newton gave the world
some insight into gravity he wrote down
a formula F equal g m1 m2 over R squared
if you remember that tells us that every
object in the universe pulls on every
other with this force called gravity and
you can see that force at work right
here and you can use that math to
predict for example how the planets will
move and goodness gracious the planets
do just what Newton's mathematics says
that they should do which is a
spectacular discovery but even so
Einstein when he started to think about
these ideas was left unsatisfied by
Newton's ideas of gravity for a number
of reasons but one concrete one that's
easy to grasp is Newton never told us
how gravity actually exerts the
influence that we associate with it how
is it that the Sun pulls on the earth or
pulls on Saturn we say it's the force of
gravity but the question is what's the
underlying mechanism by which that force
is exerted from the Sun to the earth
from the earth to the Sun and so on so
Einstein spent 10 long years trying to
figure this out and by 1915 he did
indeed come up with the answer and the
answer is that the medium the mechanism
for transmitting the force of gravity is
nothing but space in fact space and time
it's nothing but warps and curves in
space and time it's the geometry of the
universe that communicates the force of
gravity so just to get a feel for what
that all means if this is 3d space the
environment that's all around us it's
kind of hard to visualize with that so
let's go to a two-dimensional verse and
that captures all of the essential ideas
and here it is space is flat when
there's no matter present but if you
bring in the Sun Einstein says the
fabric of space curves and if you look
in the vicinity of the earth earth also
warps the environment and now if you
focus your attention on the moon you see
exactly what I am talking about Einstein
is saying that the moon is kept in orbit
because it's rolling along a valley in
the curved environment that the earth
creates and if you pull back and you
look at the motion of the earth it is
kept in orbit for exactly the same
reason the earth rolling along a valley
in the warp environment that the Sun
creates now this of course is just an
animation what Einstein worked on for
that marathon decade of research was
finding the mathematical equations
behind this picture and indeed he found
those equations are minou minus 1/2 g
m-e new articles 8 pi G T mu nu over C
to the fourth a beautiful compact
mathematical formula that describes
everything in this imagery and that
formula together with these profound
ideas constitute Einstein's general
theory of relativity
you